no I haven't distinct challenge here
okay see if you can do it I can I got
one minute one minute left in one minute
can you tell all these people what's the
one nugget you want to leave them with
that they should go back to their
offices one minute
you're gonna die I don't know if you've
heard and I'm being dead serious there's
so much opportunity the people this room
can do so much if they allow themselves
to play a game based on them being
self-aware about themselves and what
they want their legacy and skill sets to
deploy against we are in a rat trap
we're in a circle we're all saying the
same thing anytime I need nor any time I
need new business to grow I go play your
game it's that easy
i reverse-engineer the human being
that's going to make the decision I let
her him dictate the creative and we go
on our merry way and I want to shoot
myself in the face right and then I
start beating them up and saying okay I
sold you now we're doing none of that
right
legacy opportunity those things this is
an amazing time to be in this industry
if you're on the offense and it's the
worst time to be honest in this industry
if you're on the defense and 95% of you
are on the defense and if I've got one
of you to switch from that [ __ ] side to
offense today then I feel really good
about myself
you